we all know how convenient apps like
uber and lyft have made getting from
point A to point B but how safe are they
uber recently agreed to pay twenty eight
point five million dollars to settle a
class-action lawsuit about the company's
safety claims including how they screen
potential drivers turns out that one
dollar safe privacy you've been paying
was just marketing so what are they
doing to keep us safe both companies use
third-party services to background check
potential drivers but unlike most taxis
they don't use fingerprints which are
considered more foolproof some law
enforcement officials have said
background checks without fingerprints
are completely worthless and to
California district attorneys are suing
over in part for misleading customers
about their safety practices in order to
quote induce people to get into a
stranger's car
some argue that uber and lifts
background checks go far enough to
screen out people with recent criminal
history while still offering folks who
paid their debt to society a chance at
employment but that said people can and
have slipped through the system just by
signing up with a different name and
social security numbers
money might be the key here if drivers
have to get fingerprinted then they're
one step closer to being counted as
employees and not as independent
contractors and if drivers can clean
their employees and companies would have
to offer them employee benefits like
health insurance unemployment
compensation and workers comp look
getting into a stranger's car has always
carried a certain amount of danger even
long before these apps became so popular
but with their increased popularity
lawsuits have been popping up
highlighting the many risks involved
like drunk driving kidnappings
hit-and-run and sexual assaults
unfortunately there's no national law
enforcement data that tracks exactly how
frequently assaults and car services
take place so there's no way to know if
hopping in a lyft or uber is any more
dangerous than hailing a cab and it
doesn't help that nearly 75% of sexual
assaults go unreported
in Austin for example police received
more than 20 reports of unwanted sexual
contact in these vehicles in 2015
five were reported in taxi
many of the alleged assaults involved
male drivers transporting women who had
been drinking I spoke with Kelly white
of safe austin a place that supports
victims of sexual assault she said she
and her staff are very concerned with
passenger safety in these companies what
our forensic nurses are saying is this
this is an unprecedented pattern that
they have seen emerging on demand
companies provide millions of rides and
the vast majority are fine but it
doesn't mean these companies are doing
everything they can to ensure passenger
safety remember that one dollar safe
ride fee well Hoover is now calling it a
booking fee in a statement it said it's
important to ensure that the language we
use to describe safety at uber is clear
and precise but will clarity mean a
safer ride